well after 18 years of war you'd think
the United States would be finally
winding down his presence in the Persian
Gulf instead the opposite appears to be
happening at times we seem to be on the
brink of bombing Iran why are we doing
that while we're doing it primarily to
protect Saudi Arabia in Washington the
Saudis are overwhelmingly considered by
both parties to be one of our closest
allies the strange thing is that Saudi
Arabia has far closer links to the 9/11
attacks than Saddam Hussein ever did
much less Iran we're always hearing
about Iran Iran had nothing to do with
9/11 said Arabia meanwhile was so
connected to 9/11 that the families of
many 9/11 victims are seeking justice
payment as recompense for the Saudis
role so how exactly does the country and
his government get to ignore this and
what is the nature of America's
relationship with Saudi Arabia we
decided to take a closer look at that
question here's what we found in
response to the kingdom's request the
president has approved the deployment of
US forces that was Secretary of Defense
mark Esper announcing a deployment of
troops to help our quote partner in the
region not all Americans though view
saudi arabia as an ally chris Ganci a
New York City fireman lost his father on
9/11 I think the American people should
know what the Saudi involvement in 9/11
was before we commit treasure or god
forbid American blood to a cause
[Music]
dancy is one of thousands of family
members of 9/11 victims suing Saudi
Arabia their lawsuit states that Saudi
Arabia quote knowingly provided al-qaeda
with support financing and resources
that were material substantial and
critical to the success of the September
11 attacks for years Saudi Arabia
through its charities had been funneling
money to while Qaeda to get ahead in
Saudi Arabia to rise in the government
you need to show fealty to Osama bin
Laden a heavily redacted 2012 report
describes the support Saudi government
officials gave to two hijackers after
they arrived in Los Angeles the
officials gave the two al-qaeda members
quote assistance in daily activities
including providing money and helping
the hijackers get flying lessons many
Saudi government officials were in
cohorts if you will with several of the
9/11 hijackers in a sworn declaration in
2017 retired FBI Special Agents Stephen
Moore stated if the hijackers quote
would have had zero chance for success
without a support structure waiting for
them the families still want more
information to classified about Saudi
involvement and feel as if their own
government has betrayed them one would
like to think that the FBI works for the
American people not the interests of
Saudi Arabia the choosing to side of the
Saudis the Justice Department recently
cited state secrets in national security
in refusing to declassify a 2012 FBI
report that contains Saudi ties to the
9/11 hijackers in that same court filing
the DOJ decided it would only release
the name of an individual who directed
to Saudi officials to help hijackers
under protective order the obstacles
that the American government has put up
just for the truth is very disheartening
the US government has not been keen to
hold the Saudis to account in the wake
of 9/11 shortly after the attacks the
Bush administration allowed more than a
hundred Saudis including members of the
bin Laden family to leave the country on
charter two airplanes in two years ago
the Trump administration cautioned a
retired FBI agent from working for the
9/11 families I couldn't believe that my
former employer was telling me not to
give assistance to the victims of 9/11
to me it was unconscionable what really
disturbed me that's an understatement
unconscionable we asked the FBI about
Ken Williams's claim that he was told
not to work with 9/11 families they told
us they are not commenting on that they
can do that they just refused to come in